bruno daroux merci d'être avec nous une
frappe nucléaire russe mes frappes
nucléaires russes et oui est-ce que
c'est envisageable en ukraine c'est
possible à une frappe vous voulez en
nucléaire militaire oui bah écoute et à
priori ça paraît peu probable sauf si
vladimir poutine eu recours aux ce qu'on
appelle les petites armes nucléaires
tactiques on sait qu'il ya déjà eu des
accusations comme quand les russes
utilisé des bombes à fragmentation ce
qui en principe est interdite après il
ya des petites des petites bombes
nucléaires en quelque sorte qu'ils sont
utilisables
il sera interdite par le droit
international je pense qu'elles qu'elles
doivent être interdites mais les russes
les russes les possède donc est-ce
qu'ils iraient jusqu'à utiliser ça ça
paraît quand même peu probable là si on
revient ce qui s'est passé à zaporijia
c'est clairement plutôt une prise de
contrôle du nucléaire civil par les
russes parce qu'il faut rappeler par
exemple que cette centrale est la plus
importante d'ukraine dès qu'elle fournit
quand même 20% de l'électricité en
ukraine ya aussi cet objectif
énergétiques stratégiques si vous voulez
un qui va permettre au russe d'avoir
entre les mains cet outil même si la
centrale continue évidemment d'être
opéré un peu sous la contrainte par les
personnels ukrainien évidemment et puis
il ya sans doute aussi l'autre objectif
qui est de défrayer de terroriser les
populations à la fois ukrainienne est
aussi évidemment les populations en
europe sur le continent européen plus
généralement est ce que la menace d'un
tribunal international pour crimes de
guerre peut avoir une influence sur les
chefs militaires russes dans l'immédiat
je ne pense pas parce que ils sont pour
le moment pris dans une logique si vous
voulez qui maintenant été déclenchée
depuis deux semaines qui est logique de
guerre ils doivent gérer ce conflit
atteindre leurs objectifs parce qu'ils
sont également sous pression de de
vladimir poutine un tribunal
international oui sans doute ça les
ferait ça les ferait réfléchir on sait
que la la la cpi réfléchi justement a
accusé notamment vladimir poutine de
crimes de guerre et de crimes contre
l'humanité mais je ne pense pas que dans
l'immédiat ce soit leur préoccupation
principale ensuite
on verra dans quelques semaines dans
quelques mois par ailleurs il ya un
certain nombre d'industries chimiques en
ukraine quelles pourraient être les
conséquences d'une frappe au d'une
attaque à basseau bon je suis pas
spécialiste de ces questions mais
évidemment si si les russes allaient
jusqu'à frapper deux usines chimiques
évidemment ça aurait des ça aurait des
conséquences terribles sur la population
civile et si la russie parce qu'on sait
aussi que la russie possède des armes
chimiques même si là aussi c'est
interdit par le droit international si
la russie se mettaient à utiliser des
armes chimiques là aussi on franchira un
nouveau cas mais on en est pas encore là
heureusement merci beaucoup bruno daroux
merci à vous